the Democratic primary has been completely
shaken up.
I would argue in the way that it should.
It should
be shaken up by an actual debate and the performance
of candidates within that debate.
So let, let me not praise things.
I'm not trying to praise.
I was hugely critical of the disastrously
lame debate format that the DNC employed.
They had two nights of debate, 10 candidates
per night, 62nd responses, 32nd rebuttals.
Not everybody gets to comment on every issue.
This is not a format that's going to really
let you learn very much about anybody's policy
in depth.
But the polling has completely changed as
a result of how the candidates did in the
debate.
And I think that's at least a good reason
for polling the change in the sense that I
don't want polling to change because of attack
ads on TV.
I don't want polling to change because of
PAC spending.
I want polling to change because people are
watching the candidates talk and learning
more about them.
Even if in the debate format that we have,
it's more watching their personalities and
their ability to spout one liners than it
is about the depths of their policy positions.
But still debate and hearing the candidates
is the way that we should be deciding who
it is that we're going to vote for.
And the trend lines are super clear.
So to remind you, my interpretation of how
the debates went was that Camila Harris and
Elizabeth Warren probably did the best out
of the lead candidates, followed by Buddha
judge and Bernie with Joe Biden doing really
poorly and Beto O'Rourke doing absolutely
terribly.
And then most of the Zeros and ones basically
having no real impact, some because they just
don't really have many ideas.
Others because they didn't have much of a
chance to talk sort of a mixed bag among a
10, 10 or more of what we would call the Zeros
and ones.
And indeed every passing day we are seeing
the polling more closely and more precipitously
reflect exactly that interpretation of how
the debates went.
Putting the graphic up on the screen for our
video audience, Joe Biden's polling has fallen
off a cliff.
Continuing the decline from, he had this pre-debate
high of about 42% down to the mid thirties,
then to the uh, low thirties then to the high
twenties.
And now Joe Biden's polling average is down
just 26% he's still the leader, but this is
by a smaller and smaller margin every single
week.
The big winner since the debates is Kamel
Harris.
Uh, I am not a common law Harris, uh, an ardent
fan of her politics, particularly her PR prosecutorial
record in California.
I am merely telling you how she did in the
debate from an optics perspective.
She did well and now I am telling you that,
uh, she has gained a lot of ground in the
polls.
She is actually spiked into second place.
Kamala Harris in recent polls, has surpassed
Bernie Sanders and is now in second place
now averaging just over 15% in the polls,
doubling more than doubling her pre a debate
average of about 7%.
Meanwhile, Bernie has had a bit of a tough
couple of weeks.
He initially benefited from Joe Biden's decline,
but more recently Bernie has dropped into
third place.
Now a little bit more than a point behind
Kamala Harris, important to mention within
the margins of error, but officially in third
place right now.
And meanwhile, Elizabeth Warren is slow, but
steady surge continues of about a point a
month.
She is now up to 13.8% almost tying Bernie
Sanders.
And I, you know this, I like Warren and I
like Bernie.
I am taking my opinion about the candidates
out of this and just analyzing the polling
data.
If the direction, if the trajectories continue.
The trend line is that Elizabeth Warren, by
the end of this week or by early next week
may have passed Bernie Sanders and may get
into third place.
Okay.
With Bernie possibly in fourth place in a
week.
It may not happen, but it may based on the
trend lines.
Okay.
Don't kill the Messenger.
I'm just telling you what the trend lines
suggest.
This is going to be a fight.
Okay?
We have a truly contested primary here and
what's increasingly clear is that Pete Buddha
judge did not get the energy he needed from
the debate to get past 5% and become a serious
contender.
A Bedo had a terrible performance and nothing
is happening with him.
He's sitting around 2% and meanwhile nobody
else has had any really substantive change.
I got some emails from supporters of some
of the minor candidates, so I got emails from
Yang supporters who said, oh, David Yang is
up to 2% in a post debate poll.
That's like double 1% and he was at 1% before.
Well, you were telling me before that he was
really at 2% even though the polls said one,
he's still polling at zero to one in most
polls.
I like Andrew Yang.
I agree with him on some policies.
I disagree with him on others.
He's pulling zero to one in most polls.
That's just the reality.
Okay.
I bet nobody benefits from pretending things
are different than what they are.
Tulsi Gabbert supporters saying, David a Tulsa
Gabard was averaging 0.8% before the debate.
She's now at 1.4% she's nearly doubled her
support.
Listen, number one, you didn't believe the
polls before the debate.
Now you're citing them as the baseline.
Before the debate, you said there's no way
she's really pulling oh 0.8 now you're saying
she was poet polling oh 0.8 and she's doubled
it to 1.4 again.
In the last five poles.
She's just pulling 1%.
She's going nowhere.
Okay.
So my question to you, and this applies to
many of the candidates, I have a poll on my
Twitter.
Uh, when should the Zeros and ones drop out
and the options include everything from right
now all the way through.
Never just stay in it until the very end.
Follow me at d pacman vote in that poll.
Um, and I will have the results for you a
little bit later this week.